Mm.
The contemporary Internet is based on a
fundamental lie.
We all are told that it's social.
We're all told they did.
Now it's connectivity allows us to
create community,
but the reverse is actually true.
It's atomizing us.
It's not creating real community.
It's actually separating us from people
have different opinions of different
cultures.
It's increasingly an echo chamber effect
where we're only ever connected with
people who agree with us in the first
place,
but even more troubling.
These social networks aren't really
social.
They're platforms for the self that
plops for that platforms.
For us to build brands.
The clearest manifestation of this is
our obsession with the selfie.
The selfie becomes the cultural form of
the Internet.
Wherever we go,
we picture ourselves in front of
mausoleums in front of,
as I say in the book,
in front of people committing suicide at
Auschwitz at every imaginable place.
In spite of all the bad taste associated
with it.
We are in our minds at least are diluted
minds.
The center of our universe.
I argue again in terms of progress,
that we've gone back to a a pre
kapernick and understanding of the
universe where everything of revolves
around us.
There's nothing social about that and
the end consequences two fold.
Firstly,
we're making complete fools of ourselves
that narcissism,
that indulgence is embarrassing,
and in the long run,
we're going to regret it both as a
species and individually.
When we look back at those absurd photos
of herself where we're shamelessly
exposing,
uh,
our own self importance,
we're going to be severely embarrassed
by it.
But secondly,
it also reflects the reality of the
Internet.
It's about the individual.
It's not about the social and the
Internet is alienating,
isolating,
fragmenting ourselves.
It's weakening community.
That's of course the reason why it
hasn't generated real political
movements.
It creates explosions.
The Arab spring occupy,
but no legacy,
no political parties,
no movements,
no real foundations of political change.